Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is how intense Nova Kane sounds. Oh, wow! Imagine how it looks. Is there more? Yeah, big time. Nova Kane. Pulling theaters March 14th.
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告内容、系列节目的抢先收听，并成为我们备受喜爱的聊天社区的会员，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。这就是“新星”凯恩听起来的强度。哦，天哪！想象一下它看起来是什么样子的。还有吗？是的，非常多。诺娃·凯恩。3 月 14 日登陆各大影院。
TD Direct Investing offers live support. So whether you're a newbie or a seasoned pro, you can make your investing steps count. And if you're like me and think a TFSA stands for Total Fund Savings Adventure, maybe reach out to TD Direct Investing. rule your family vacation. Start planning your trip to the ultimate playground at visitcalifornia.com. Marianne is the embodiment of the French Republic. Marianne represents the permanent values that found her citizens' attachment to the Republic Liberté Équalité Fraternité. The earliest representation of a woman wearing a Frigian cap, an allegorical figure of Liberté and the République, made their appearance at the time of the French Revolution.
道明直接投资提供实时支持。因此，无论您是新手还是经验丰富的专业人士，您都可以让您的每一步投资都算数。如果您和我一样，认为 TFSA 代表总基金储蓄冒险，也许可以联系道明直接投资。统治您的家庭度假。开始规划前往终极游乐场的旅程，请访问 visitcalifornia.com。玛丽安是法兰西共和国的化身。玛丽安代表了她的公民对共和国“自由、平等、博爱”的永恒价值观。头戴弗里吉亚帽、作为“自由”和“共和国”象征的女性的最早形象，出现在法国大革命时期。
The origins of the name Marianne are uncertain. Marianne was a very common first name in the 18th century and she thus came to represent the people. The counter-revolutionaries used the name derisively when referring to the République. So Tom, that was the website of the Elysee Palace talking about the great symbol of the French Republic, Marianne. So this is a symbol that emerges at the point that we've just got to in the great narrative of the French Revolution, the summer and autumn of 1792.
“玛丽安”这个名字的起源并不确定。在 18 世纪，“玛丽安”是一个非常普通的教名，因此她逐渐成为了人民的代表。反革命分子在提到共和国时，曾带有嘲讽意味地使用这个名字。汤姆，那是爱丽舍宫的网站，谈到了法兰西共和国的伟大象征——玛丽安。所以，这是一个在法国大革命宏大叙事中，也就是 1792 年的夏天和秋天，我们刚刚到达的节点上浮现出来的象征。
We heard last time about the terrible September massacres that took place as the Prussians were advancing on Paris. And it's of course at this point that people are singing the Marseilles, the marching song of the army of the Rhine that has swept through the capital. But it's also at this point that people are light upon a new symbol of France, which is this figure of Marianne. Will Barron Marianne, who is this woman wearing the fridgen cap, the Liberty cap, long flowing hair, will become the emblem of France itself. And I think it's really striking that the two of the kind of emblematic embodiments
我们上次听说了可怕的九月大屠杀，那是随着普鲁士军队向巴黎推进而发生的。当然，也是在这个时候，人们高唱着《马赛曲》，这首莱茵军团的进行曲席卷了整个首都。但同样是在这个时候，人们偶然发现了法兰西的一个新象征，也就是玛丽安这个人物。威尔·巴伦·玛丽安，这位头戴弗里吉亚帽（自由帽）、留着长长的飘逸秀发的女性，将成为法国本身的象征。我认为这真的很引人注目，现代法国的两种标志性化身
of modern France, so the Marseillaise, its national anthem, and the figure of emblematic embodiments of modern France. So the Massey is its national anthem and the figure of Marianne, the embodiment of France herself, emerging precisely these months that the summer going into the autumn of 1792. And I guess the previous episode that we did where we looked at the September massacres, I mean, it didn't really portray the revolution in a great light, did it? I mean, if we're absolutely honest. But I think this kind of reminds us that even while people are being dragged out of prisons and hacked to death, there is also an absolutely invigorating and inspiring sense of optimism and hope that is inspiring terrible deeds, yes, but also, you know, it's rallying people to the barricades and it's giving people dreams
现代法国的标志性化身。所以马赛是它的国歌，而玛丽安的形象，法国自身的化身，恰好在 1792 年夏秋之交的这几个月里浮现。我想，我们之前制作的那集回顾九月大屠杀的节目，我的意思是，它并没有把大革命描绘成一个多么光彩的形象，不是吗？我的意思是，如果我们绝对诚实的话。但我认为这某种程度上提醒了我们，尽管人们被从监狱里拖出来并被砍死，但也有一种绝对令人振奋、鼓舞人心的乐观和希望感，它激发了可怕的行动，是的，但同时，你知道的，它也号召人们走上街头，赋予人们对美好未来的梦想。
of a better future. Yes. A future in which all of the people of France will have a stake. So you mentioned at the end of the last episode, you left us with this absolute cliffhanger that the Prussians are advancing on Paris, but you also talked about how there is this new political settlement, there's this national convention and elections are being held to it. And you said, you know, if the Prussians break into Paris and maybe the convention will never even meet a spoiler alert, the Prussians break into Paris, then maybe the convention will
是的。一个法国所有人民都拥有利益的未来。所以你在上一集的结尾提到过，你给我们留下了这样一个绝对扣人心弦的悬念：普鲁士人正在向巴黎推进，但你也谈到了有一个新的政治契约，有一个国民公会，并且正在为其举行选举。你说过，你知道，如果普鲁士人闯入巴黎，也许国民公会甚至永远不会开会——剧透警告，普鲁士人闯入了巴黎，那么也许国民公会
never even meet. A spoiler alert, the Prussians don't end up meeting, advancing on Paris for reasons that we'll discuss in the next episode. And the National Convention does meet and it meets on the 20th September. And the deputies who are going there, they're all going to the Tuileries where the royal family had previously been based until the massacre of their guards and their removal to what ultimately is their prison. So this is now the center of the convention, which is an expression of, in a way, popular
永远不会开会。剧透警告，普鲁士人并没有最终在向巴黎推进时相遇，原因我们将在下一集中讨论。国民公会确实召开了，它于 9 月 20 日开会。即将前往那里的代表们，他们都将前往杜伊勒里宫，王室成员此前一直以那里为基地，直到他们的卫兵遭到屠杀，他们被转移到最终成为他们监狱的地方。所以这里现在成为了国民公会的中心，从某种意义上说，它是人民主权的一种表达。
sovereignty. What is striking about this, and it's not just in the French context, but in the context of the whole of global history, is that this is a near universal suffrage for men. There are no distinctions of class, there are no distinctions of property. People may remember back in the mists of time that we talked about originally there was this idea of active and passive citizens, weren't there, that active citizens you had to have certain property qualifications, you couldn't have certain professions. All that has gone. All males basically over the age of 21 now have the vote. And I think this is a kind of noble and inspiring moment in history.
对此引人注目的是，这不仅在法国的语境下，而且在整个全球历史的语境下，都是针对男性的近乎普遍的普选权。没有阶级的区别，没有财产的区别。人们可能还记得，在时间的迷雾中，我们曾谈到最初存在着积极公民和消极公民的概念，不是吗？积极公民你必须具备一定的财产资格，你不能从事某些职业。这一切都消失了。现在基本上所有 21 岁以上的男性都拥有投票权。我认为这是历史中一个高尚且鼓舞人心的时刻。
No matter what your views on the revolution might be, Dominic, would you disagree with that or not? I mean, maybe you don't you think? Yeah, I don't find it inspiring at all. Well, I don't think everybody should have the vote. So that's fine. Inference for me in the French revolution. Well, I don't think everybody should have the vote. So It's been me in the French Revolutionaries. So who do you think should not have the vote? I probably wouldn't give it to anybody, but I definitely raised the age Thing I think probably 35 40 and also property. I think you need to be a property you to own property
无论你对大革命的看法如何，多米尼克，你会不同意这一点还是不赞成？我的意思是，也许你不会？你觉得呢？是的，我一点也不觉得鼓舞人心。嗯，我不认为每个人都应该有投票权。所以没关系。法国大革命对我的影响。嗯，我不认为每个人都应该有投票权。所以对法国大革命的人来说是这样的。那你觉得谁不应该有投票权呢？我可能不会把它给任何人，但我绝对会提高年龄要求，比如35岁、40岁，还有财产。我认为你需要成为一个财产所有者，你需要拥有财产
Don't you fine? Okay, the voice of John Bull. How does he got no stake in the system? I think you know that you are just teasing. I'm sure you are a Democrat. Tom, that's thrown you so much. You don't know. I can't believe you. I don't really know. I don't think I've ever seen you so.
没关系？好吧，约翰·牛顿（John Bull）的声音。他怎么在体制内毫无利益相关？我想你知道你只是在开玩笑。我确信你是个民主主义者。汤姆，这把你难倒了吧。你都不知道。我真不敢相信你。我真的不知道。我想我从来没见过你这样。
I don't really know how to reply to that. Come on. This is, this is universal suffrage. This is democracy in action. It's the closest to the modern ideal of democracy that we have. It's an ideal that Britain now cleaves to. So in that sense, you could say that Britain is inspired by this example as well. And Marianne kind of becomes the symbol of it.
我真的不知道该如何回应这个。拜托。这是普选权。这是付诸实践的民主。这是我们所拥有的最接近现代民主理想的理念。这是一个英国现在也笃信的理想。从这个意义上说，你可以说英国也受到了这个榜样的启发。而玛丽安某种程度上成为了它的象征。
And the reason for that is the motion that is brought before the deputies the day after they meet on the 21st of September when they essentially vote to abolish monarchy. Royalty shall be abolished in France is the motion. And this is where the woman who comes to be called Marianne is introduced because again, to quote from the Elysée palace, Marianne is the embodiment of the French Republic. And so how does it come about? How does this woman appear? How does she come to be called Marianne? It's actually not until the middle of the 19th century that she's kind of universally called Marianne. But the Elise Palace thing that I read at the beginning is wrong. Am I not right in thinking that we know better than the Elise Palace?
原因在于 9 月 21 日他们开会后的第二天提交给代表们的动议，当时他们基本上投票废除了君主制。动议是：在法国应废除皇室。这就是那位后来被称为玛丽安的女性被引入的原因，因为再次引用爱丽舍宫的话，玛丽安是法兰西共和国的化身。那么这是怎么发生的呢？这个女人是如何出现的？她是怎么被称为玛丽安的？其实直到 19 世纪中叶，她才被普遍称为玛丽安。但是我刚开始读的爱丽舍宫的那段话是错的。我没想错吧，我们难道比爱丽舍宫更懂吗？
No one. So the Elise Palace said, you know, who knows where the name comes from? We know precisely where the name comes from. The name comes from this poem that is written in, I think, October, is it October 1792? To mark the founding of the Republic. And interestingly, the poem is not in French. I mean, that's what makes it so fascinating. Yeah, so it's by a guy called Guillaume Lavabre, who is writing in Languedoc, and he writes
没有人。所以爱丽舍宫说，你知道的，谁知道这个名字从哪里来？我们确切地知道这个名字来自哪里。这个名字来自这首写于——我想是 10 月，是 1792 年 10 月吗？——为了纪念共和国的成立而写的一首诗。有趣的是，这首诗不是用法语写的。我的意思是，这就是它如此迷人的地方。是的，所以它是由一个叫纪尧姆·拉瓦布尔（Guillaume Lavabre）的人写的，他用朗格多克语写作，他写了
this poem called La Guerérison de Marianne, The Healing of Marianne in French. And in that poem, Marianne is clearly an embodiment of the new republic that's been proclaimed. And this is the first equation of the republic with a woman called Marianne. But unlike the Marseilles, it doesn't really spread because it's not as accessible and it takes a long, long time for that equation to kind of spread. As I said, it's not really until the 19th century. And so originally the figure of France as a woman, she's not called Marianne, she is very clearly liberty and specifically Republican liberty. And the emergence of an image of France as a woman who embodies liberty, as we said, this is emerging at the same time as the Marseilles is being enshrined as the national anthem.
这首名为《玛丽安的治愈》（La Guerérison de Marianne）的诗，法语即 The Healing of Marianne。在这首诗中，玛丽安显然是刚宣布成立的新共和国的化身。这是共和国与一个名叫玛丽安的女性的首次等同。但与《马赛曲》不同的是，它并没有真正传播开来，因为它不够通俗易懂，而且这种等同花了很长很长的时间才得以传播。正如我所说，直到 19 世纪才真正如此。因此，最初作为女性形象的法国并不叫玛丽安，她非常明确地代表着自由，特别是共和主义的自由。而一个将法国具象化为体现自由的女性形象的出现，正如我们所说，这与《马赛曲》被奉为国歌是在同一时期出现的。
And so it's expressive of all the convulsions, all the excitements, all the kind of incredible process of change that these months in 1792 that we've been covering in the previous series and in this series are generating. And she appears very precisely in the wake of the abolition of the monarchy when the royal seal, great golden seal of Louis XVI is melted down and reconfigured. And on the new seal of the Republic, this is where Liberty, who will become Marianne, first appears. So the figure of Liberty, this is, we've talked so much about the influence of the Romans in particular on the French revolutionists. So this is a very obviously classical figure, basically a goddess holding the
因此，它表达了所有这些动荡、所有的兴奋、以及我们在前一个系列和本系列中一直在探讨的 19 世纪 90 年代这几个月正在产生的令人难以置信的变革过程。她非常精准地出现在君主制被废除之后，当时路易十六巨大的金色皇家国玺被熔化并重新塑造。而在共和国的新国玺上，这位将成为玛丽安的“自由”女神首次亮相。因此，“自由”的形象，这就是——我们已经谈了太多关于罗马人对法国革命者的影响。所以这显然是一个非常古典的形象，基本上是一个手持
fasces with an axe and a Liberty cap. That's right. Isn't it? So do you feel a bit of Athena about this figure maybe? Well, she's I mean, she's Liberty. She's a classical abstraction given female form. And as with so much about the French Revolution, it actually has its roots in the Ancien Regime. So the painters, illustrators had been showing Liberty as this kind of goddess in the years before the revolution breaks out. So there was a particularly famous illustration in a book about Henry IV, who was the great hero of France before the revolution. He was seen as the people's king. And this
束棒、带有斧头和自由帽的女神。没错。不是吗？所以你觉得这个形象有点雅典娜的感觉吗？嗯，她——我的意思是，她是自由。她是一个被赋予女性形式的古典抽象概念。正如法国大革命的许多方面一样，它实际上植根于旧制度。因此，在大革命爆发前的几年里，画家和插画家一直将自由描绘成这种女神。因此，在一本关于亨利四世的书中有过一幅特别著名的插图，亨利四世是大革命前法国的伟大英雄。他被视为人民的国王。而这幅
illustration shows him being carried up to heaven by Liberty, by this goddess. This is kind of allegorical illustrations and paintings that really have very little cut through, but it's kind of there on the margins. And actually, I think you could say that the very value of Liberty is that she is a kind of a bit of an empty cipher. She's a kind of an abstraction onto which you can project things. So Lynn Hunt, the great scholar of the kind of the culture of the French Revolution, particular interest in the role of women in the revolution, she wrote about the figure of Liberty that she represented the virtues so desired by the new order, the transcendence of localism,
插图展示了他被自由女神、被这位女神带上了天堂。这种寓意性的插图和画作实际上并没有产生太大的影响，但它确实存在于边缘。事实上，我认为你可以说，“自由”这个价值本身的意义在于，她有点像一个空洞的密码。她是一种抽象概念，你可以把各种东西投射到上面。因此，林恩·亨特（Lynn Hunt）——法国大革命文化史的伟大学者，对大革命中女性角色有着特别的兴趣——她关于自由女神的形象写道，她代表了新秩序如此渴望的美德，超越了地方主义、
superstition and particularity in the name of a more disciplined and universalistic worship. Liberty was an abstract quality based on reason she belonged to no group, to no particular place. Which is another way of saying that the whole point of Liberty is that she's quite boring. She does not bring any baggage. And it's important because of course the marketing of Liberty is also a marketing of the Republic and she's being stamped on the seal at the point where people don't really know what the Republic is about, what's it going to be? It doesn't have any of the attributes that a thousand year old monarchy has. It doesn't bring the inheritance of symbols that France,
迷信和特殊性，以更具纪律性和普遍性的崇拜的名义。自由是一种基于理性的抽象品质，她不属于任何群体，不属于任何特定的地方。换句话说，自由的全部意义在于她其实很无聊。她不带有任何包袱。这很重要，因为当然，自由的市场营销也是共和国的市场营销，她被印在国玺上时，人们并不真正知道共和国是关于什么的，它会变成什么样？它不具备一个拥有一千年历史的君主制所拥有的任何属性。它没有带来法国（特别是皇室法国）绝对沉浸其中的象征遗产。相反，她——她有点像罗伯斯庇尔。她有点冷酷、沉着、死板、有美德。当然，这里有两个明显的对比。因此，即使她后来被称为玛丽安，她也不是基督徒。她不是圣母。她是一个非基督徒的圣母。我认为，正如我们将在下一系列的问题中所看到的，你对巴黎圣母院（我们的夫人，圣母）的处理在适当的时候将成为大革命的一个尖锐问题。所以，自由玛丽安不是圣母玛利亚。但当然，同时，她也不是一个世俗女王。更准确地说。她不是玛丽·安托瓦内特。她不是一个贵族女性，而通常那些女性是——你知道的，画作、形象。她们来自贵族阶层。
particularly royal France, has been absolutely saturated in. And instead she's, she's kind of almost Rob's Pierre. She's kind of chilly, poised, uptight, virtuous. And of course, there are the two obvious contrasts here. So even though she will come to be called Mary Anne, she's not Christian. She's not the Virgin. She is a Virgin who is not Christian. And I think that's, you know, as we will see in a problem in our next series, what you do with Notre Dame, Our Lady, the Virgin will be a pointed issue in due course for the revolution. So, Liberty Marianne is not the Virgin Mary. But of course, also, she's not an earthly queen. and more precisely. She is not Marie Antoinette She is not an aristocratic woman and generally women who are you know paintings images. They're from the aristocracy
自由的全部意义在于她不是。对吧？她是没有阶级的，我想是的，不是吗？我的意思是，她没有被任何东西所定义，而且因为她是古董，她不代表当代法国的任何特定群体。她是普遍的。
The whole point of Liberty is she is not right. She's classless. I suppose isn't she? I mean, she's not defined by any and because she's antique She doesn't represent any particular group in contemporary France. She's universal. Exactly. And, and as you said, there are kind of obviously echoes of Athena, the Greek goddess of wisdom. So in due course, she comes to be shown wearing a helmet.
完全正确。而且，正如你所说，明显有雅典娜（希腊智慧女神）的影子。因此，在适当的时候，她开始被描绘成头戴头盔的样子。
She's shown kind of trampling down various monsters representing counter revolution and monarchy or whatever. And so with pretty much within a year of her appearance, first appearance on the, the, the, the great seal of France, she's starting to become a bit more proactive. And of course the classic expression of this isn't in this French revolution, but in a later one in Delacroix's great painting of, of Liberty leading the people. I'm sure people will have seen it. Liberty standing there in her Liberty cap urging the revolutionaries on. And I think you get a kind of presentiment of that in
她被描绘成践踏各种代表反革命和君主制的怪物的形象，诸如此类。因此，几乎在她首次出现在法国伟大国玺上的一年之内，她开始变得更加积极主动。当然，这方面的经典表现不在这次法国大革命中，而是在后来的德拉克罗瓦（Delacroix）的伟大画作《自由引导人民》中。我相信人们都见过。自由女神站在那里，头戴自由帽，敦促着革命者前进。我想你在
the first revolution as well. But Dom, I think that's kind of interesting question about this, that France, Liberty, the Republic, the Revolution are all being imaged by this, this figure of a beautiful, slightly chilly woman. But what does it mean? I mean, does it have any resonance at all for the actual women who were living through the Revolution? So we started the entire cycle of French revolution series with a woman, with Marie Antoinette and the extraordinary misogyny of the attacks on her. And then although virility, masculine friendship, martial virtue, and all of
第一次革命中也能感受到这种预兆。但是多姆，我认为关于这一点有一个相当有趣的问题，那就是法国、自由、共和国、革命都被这个美丽、略带冷酷的女性形象所塑造。但这意味着什么呢？我的意思是，对于那些亲历大革命的真实女性来说，这有任何共鸣吗？所以我们以一位女性——玛丽·安托瓦内特以及对她攻击中非凡的厌女症——开启了整个法国大革命系列的周期。然后，尽管阳刚之气、男性友谊、尚武美德以及所有这一切，这些男性的理念对法国大革命的精神风貌至关重要。也曾有过一些时刻，不是吗，女性占据了舞台中心。所以我想你做过一集关于……的节目，呃，
that, these kind of, these masculine ideas have mattered enormously to the ethos of the French revolution. There have been moments, haven't there, when women have taken center stage. So I think you did an episode about the, um, the women's March on Versailles. When the market women go and bring back the King and Marat Renet and the symbolism of it being the market women, I think is really important there, isn't it? Yeah.
妇女进军凡尔赛。当市场上的女商人们前往并带回国王和玛丽·安托瓦内特时，市场女商人们作为象征这一点在那里真的非常重要，不是吗？是的。
And then of course you've got women who are prominent in the sonculot, who are storming the Tuileries, who are shouting slogans in the streets. So it's not just a man's revolution by any means. Absolutely. So I think we talked before in the previous series about how the idea of the sonculot, the man who is wearing trousers rather than the britches that is kind of the traditional markers of wealth and status, how important dress is. man who is wearing trousers rather than the britches that is kind of the traditional markers of wealth and status, how important dress is. And there are female sonculote, you know,
然后当然还有那些在无套裤汉中很显眼的女性，她们冲进杜伊勒里宫，在街头高喊口号。所以这绝不仅仅是一场男人的革命。绝对的。所以我想我们在前一个系列中讨论过无套裤汉的概念，穿长裤而不是作为财富和地位传统标志的马裤的男人，服装是多么重要。穿长裤而不是作为财富和地位传统标志的马裤的男人，服装是多么重要。也有女性无套裤汉，你知道的，
they're not wearing trousers, but they're wearing kind of coarse woolen skirts, and they're wearing the wooden clogs that are the markers of a sonculote. And they wear the carmagnol, this kind of jacket that has ultimately come from kind of revolutionaries in Italy. And because of the role that they played in bringing the King and Queen from Versailles to Paris back in 1789, and as you said, because of the role that they also play in helping the patriot heroes who stormed the Tuileries in the summer of 1792. They are enshrined as a group, as kind of mothers of the nation. But I think there is a crucial difference between the way that women are portrayed in revolutionary
她们不穿长裤，但她们穿着粗羊毛裙子，穿着作为无套裤汉标志的木鞋。她们穿着卡马尼奥尔（carmagnol），这种最初来自意大利革命者的夹克。由于她们在 1789 年将国王和王后从凡尔赛带到巴黎的过程中发挥了作用，而且正如你所说，由于她们在协助爱国英雄们于 1792 年夏天冲进杜伊勒里宫的过程中也发挥了作用。她们作为一个群体被奉为国母。但我认为，女性在革命宣传中的描绘方式与男性的描绘方式之间存在着一个至关重要的区别，我们谈到了那些名字在历史上久久回荡的革命人物。所以每个人都听说过罗伯斯庇尔、马拉或德穆兰。这些都是在历史长河中挺立的个人。但女性大体上却没有。而这种趋势可以追溯到大革命本身。所以我们谈到了马拉，他当然在适当的时候会在浴室里与一位不太喜欢他的女性会面，但在那之前，他
propaganda and the way that men are, we've talked about revolutionary figures whose names continue to reverberate down. So everyone has heard of Ross Pierre or Marat or Desmoulins. These are individuals who kind of stand tall in the pages of history. But women by and large don't. And that is a trend that goes back to the revolution itself. So we talked about Mara who of course in due course will have a meeting with a woman who's not very keen on him in his bath but before that he he was very proud of
对自己作为一名女权主义者感到非常自豪。他把自己不仅标榜为人民之友，更具体地标榜为女性之友。但当他书写女性时，他从不点名具体的个人。这总是关于女性的整体。她们是一群受某种激活动能和激活情感力量启发的庞大人性群体。她们是自发的。这是凡尔赛游行被描绘方式的关键。她们不是个人，通过这种方式，她们得到了保护。她们没有干涉男性的领域。即使当她们没有游行去凡尔赛或攻击宫殿之类的时候，这种情况也一直在继续，因为巴黎的女性——尤其是
himself as a feminist. He marketed himself not just as a friend of the people but specifically as the friend of women. But when he writes about women, he never names individuals. It's always about the totality of women. They are a kind of a mass of humanity who are inspired by a kind of animating energy and animating emotional power. They're spontaneous. This is key to how the march on Versailles is portrayed. They are not individuals and in that way they are kept safe. They're not intruding on the kind of masculine sphere. And this carries on even when they're not kind of marching on Versailles or attacking palaces or whatever, because women in Paris in particular, which
革命活动的中心——是非常非常热心的旁观者。因此，特别是来自市场的女性、渔妇们作为政治迷的这种感觉非常非常强烈。她们通常不被允许参与公开辩论本身，但她们被允许进入聚集旁观者的看台，当国民公会开会时，她们在公会中占据公共席位。大体上，男革命者对此非常赞赏。所以当发现女性
is the cockpit of revolutionary activity, they are very, very keen spectators. So the sense of particularly women from the markets, people, you know, fish wives, as political junkies, is very, very strong. They're generally not allowed to contribute to the public debate itself, but they are given access to the galleries where spectators gather, they take up public seats at the convention when it meets. And by and large, male revolutionaries are very appreciative of this. So there's one when it turns out that women are not being allowed
由于聚集的人太多而无法进入观看政治会议时，有一位雅各宾派代表摆出罗马人的姿态，这完全是你可以想象李维或普鲁塔克早期书页中某个人会说的话，他命令搬来更多的长凳，以便她们能够坐下。他告诉其他代表，这些是家庭的母亲。她们堪比古罗马。也许正因为罗伯斯庇尔特别擅长扮演罗马人，所以他成为了这些前来为各个雅各宾派代表欢呼和支持的女性的特别宠儿。事实上，罗伯斯庇尔尽管有着略带冷酷的无性恋形象，
in to watch a political session because too many people have gathered there. And one of the Jacobin deputies kind of posing like a Roman, it's exactly the kind of thing that you could imagine someone in the early pages of Livy or Plutarch saying, he orders that more benches be brought in so that they can sit down. These are mothers of families, he tells the other delegates. They are worthy of ancient Rome. And it may be because Robespierre in particular is so good at playing the Roman, that he is a particular favorite of these women who come to cheer and support the various Jacobin deputies. And the fact that Robespierre, despite his kind of slight image of Chile asexuality,
却是个绝对的万人迷。我的意思是，她们，你知道的，他有所有这些狂热女粉丝。这被他的敌人注意到了，并给他们带来了一定程度的困惑，我想。但这难道不是因为那种形象吗，我想说，那种冷酷感，我认为这正是吸引力所在，不是吗？女性认为我可能是那个融化冰冷、不可腐蚀的心的人。就是这样。但实际上我们这里只是在讨论作为旁观者的女性看着男人，
is an absolute heartthrob. I mean, they, you know, he has all these groupies. It's kind of noted by his enemies and causes them some degree of puzzlement I think. But is it not because of that image, I would say, the chilliness and the, I think that is the draw, isn't it? The women think I could be the one who melts the ice cold, incorruptible heart. All that. But actually we're just talking about women as spectators here watching men,
但也有，嗯，我们有一个特别的女性。所以我们讨论了玛丽安·安托瓦内特，但在革命者这一边，我们在近期的剧集中多次提到过一个特别的女性，她实际上是一个特工。她拥有真正的政治影响力，那就是罗兰夫人。所以跟我讲讲罗兰夫人吧。所以她是吉伦特派一位大臣的妻子，她本质上是经营革命沙龙的女性的原型。
but there are, well, we've had one woman in particular. So we talked about Marion Twinnett, but on the side of the revolutionaries, we've had one woman in particular that we've mentioned a few times in the more recent episodes who actually is an, an agent. She has genuine political influence and that is Madam Roland. So tell me about Madam Roland. So she is the wife of a gyrondin minister and she essentially is the archetype of the woman who runs a revolutionary salon.
因此，沙龙的概念——权贵们聚在一起讨论哲学或时政等。同样，这也是从旧制度继承下来的，但罗兰夫人建立的是那种经典的革命沙龙，但她不仅仅是一个女主人。我的意思是，正如你所说，她是一个行动者。从某种意义上说，她比她的丈夫更有魄力、更有活力、更具主动性。所以她就是提出在全法国招募志愿兵（Fédérés）这个想法的人。这些人将唱着《马赛曲》从法国南部赶来，比如说。所以那是她的主意。在 1792 年的头几个月里，随着皇家宪法开始瓦解，
So the idea of a salon where, um, movers and shakers meet up, discuss philosophy or current politics or whatever. Again, it's something that is inherited from the Ancien Régime, but Madame Royleau sets up the kind of the classic revolutionary salon, but she's not just a hostess. I mean, as you said, she is an actor. She, in a way, I mean, is much more forceful, much more dynamic, much more proactive than her husband. So she is the person who comes up with the idea of recruiting the Federa from across France. These are the people who will come singing the mass AAs from the south of France, for instance. So that's her idea. And in the early months of 1792, as the royal constitution is starting to implode,
她四处写信。所以她写信给布里索和他的同事们，指责他们是在浪费时间，在国王的政权明显奄奄一息的时候还支持他。她敦促她的丈夫支持暂停国王的职务。他对此一直有些犹豫不决。所以她非常强硬。她有着非常坚定的意见，而且由于她在沙龙中的地位，由于她拥有所有这些惊人的关系，她能够让自己的意见广为人知。
she is writing letters left, right and center. So she's writing letters to Briso and his colleagues, accusing them of being time wasters, of supporting the king when his regime is clearly on its uppers. She pushes her husband to support the suspension of the King. He'd been kind of hesitant about this. So she's very forceful. She has very strong opinions and she is able because of her position in the salon, because she has all these amazing connections to let her opinions be known.
它们产生了影响。但同样地，她自己并不认为女性应该在公开政治中扮演角色。所以她不邀请其他女性去她的沙龙。你知道的，那是她自己的，也唯独是她自己的。这非常“玛格丽特·撒切尔”，不是吗？这就是玛格丽特·撒切尔管理她政府的方式。所以罗兰夫人——我不认为撒切尔夫人会走到这一步，但她说女性必须激发政治努力，却又不能显得在为之做贡献。你提到了玛丽·安托瓦内特。我觉得这真的很引人注目。
They have an impact. But again, this she does not herself think that women should play a role in kind of public politics. So she doesn't invite other women to her salon. You know, it's hers and hers alone. That's very Margaret Thatcher, isn't it? It's how Margaret Thatcher ran her government. So Madame Rolland, I don't think Mrs. Thatcher would go this far, but she says women must inspire political endeavor, yet without seeming to be contributing to it. And you mentioned Marie Antoinette. I think it's really striking.
罗兰夫人对玛丽·安托瓦内特非常非常敌视。原因之一是她谴责玛丽·安托瓦内特对国王以及因此对整个政治产生了恶劣的影响。因此，她谴责她所说的“皇家帷幕后面丝绸的沙沙声”。这种观点认为，当路易十六由其大臣伺候时，玛丽·安托瓦内特就在屏风后面低声细语。当然，这其中的讽刺意味在于，这正是她的许多敌人——罗伯斯庇尔、丹东、山岳派、那些反对吉伦特派的人（而罗兰夫人是吉伦特派）——
Madame Roland is very, very hostile to Marie Antoinette. And one of the reasons for this is that she condemns Marie Antoinette for being a malign influence on the king and therefore on politics generally. And so she condemns what she calls the faint rustling of silk behind the royal curtain. The idea that when Louis XVI is being attended by his ministers, Marie Antoinette is there kind of whispering from behind screens. And of course, the irony of that is that these are precisely the terms in which many of her enemies, so Robespierre, Danton, the Montagnards, the people who are opposed to the Girondins and Madame Rolland is a Girondin,
用来谴责她的措辞，说她是一个藏在帷幕后面窃窃私语的人。他们直截了当地说她是新的蓬帕杜夫人。她是新的杜巴利夫人。她是那个腐蚀并诱惑了那些蜂拥在她身周围的头脑简单、轻信的男人的过度强势的女性宠臣。我的意思是，她基本上把这纳入了一套标准的恶魔化叙事中，不是吗？确实如此。这是为了把她的丈夫塑造成新路易十六，
this is how they condemn her as someone who is kind of hiding behind a curtain, whispering. They literally say she is the new Madame de Pompadour. She is the new Madame du Barry. She is the over mighty female favorite who has corrupted and seduced this sort of, the slack minded gullible men who flock around her. I mean, it's, she fits it basically into a standard demonology, doesn't she? She does. And it's to cast her husband as the new Louis the 16th,
唯利是图、逆来顺受、被阉割般的形象。在那年夏天，随着吉伦特派与那些更偏左的人（你可以这样表达）之间的紧张关系加剧，她成为了许多无套裤汉痛恨的人物。我猜她会是谁呢？有点像波利·托因比（Polly Toynbee）也许吧。没错。蓝领特朗普选民谈论希拉里·克林顿的方式就是这样，例如，唠唠叨叨。她能有今天全靠她的丈夫。她总是对我们指手画脚，告诉我们什么对我们好。诸如此类的事情。我认为这有助于——实际上，你知道的，她的角色以及人们对她的言论，
kind of venal, pliable, emasculated. And over the course of that summer, as tensions between the Girondins and those who are kind of further to the left, you might put it like that, she becomes a kind of hate figure for many of the sonculot. She's, I guess, what would she be? Kind of Polly Toynbee perhaps. Right. That's the way that which blue collar Trump voters talked about Hillary Clinton, for example, nagging. She's only got where she has because of her husband. She's always telling us off and telling us what's good for us. All of that kind of thing. And I think that it helped, it actually, you know, her role and the things that are said
以及针对她的厌女症，具有讽刺意味的是，这借鉴了先前谴责玛丽·安托瓦内特的厌女症传统。它有助于使山岳派和吉伦特派之间的政治分歧两极分化。而且引人注目的是，山岳派——那些最左翼的人，那些最致力于自由、平等，当然还有博爱（fraternity，兄弟情谊，而不是姐妹情谊）理想的人——我认为，他们最准备将女性对革命中主导地位的争夺视为反革命行为。当然，这些——在最左翼，罗伯斯庇尔、马拉等等，这些
about her and the misogyny that is directed at her ironically kind of, you know, is drawing on the traditions of misogyny that had earlier condemned Marie Antoinette. It helps to polarise the political division between the Montagnards and the Girondins. And it's kind of striking that it is the Montagnard, those who are furthest left, those who are most committed to perhaps to the ideals of liberty, equality, and of course, fraternity, brotherhood, not sisterhood, who are, I think, the readiest to see female claims to a commanding role in the revolution as actually being counter-revolutionary. And of course these, you know, on the farthest left, the Robespierre, the Marat, so on, these
是最多地认同古代美德模型的男人，认同斯巴达人，认同早期共和国的罗马人。我们知道罗马人对女性参与政治是怎么想的。他们认为这是一件糟糕的事情。是的，因为他们认为——斯巴达人典型地认为女性的角色是妻子和母亲。换句话说，献身于男性公民的女性，她们的角色是为他们服务，使他们能够履行爱国职责，然后为他们生下更多能够继续为共和国服务的儿子。这显然借鉴了斯巴达和罗马的理想。这是一个从一开始就存在于
are the men who most identify with the model of antique virtue, with Spartans, with kind of the Romans of the early Republic. And we know what the Romans thought about women being involved in politics. They thought it was a terrible thing. Yes, because they saw the role, you know, Spartans, paradigmatically, saw the role of women to be wives and to be mothers. So in other words, women who are dedicated to the male citizen, their role is to serve them, to enable them to do their patriotic duty, and then to give them more sons who can continue to serve the Republic. And this is very clearly drawing on kind of Spartan and Roman ideals. And it's an ideal that right from the beginning is there in
所有举办的节日、修辞以及所有这类事情中的理想。这就留下了一个问题，我想我们也许应该在休息后试着回答这个问题：是否真的有女性在争取全面的政治权利？如果有的话，对她们的回应是什么？好吧，对于喜欢《历史的 rest》的人来说好消息是，确实有这样的女性，否则就不会有下半场了。休息后回来，我们将认识其中的两位。到时候见。
all the festivals that are staged, in the rhetoric, all of that kind of thing. And it leaves open the question, which I think we should maybe try and answer after a break. Are there actually any women who are pushing for full political rights? And if there are, what is the response to them? Well, the good news for people who like the rest is history is that there are such women because otherwise there would be no second half. So return after the break and we will meet two of them. See you then.
今天的节目由 Disney Plus 独家首映的全新原创剧集《千击》赞助播出。新剧集《千击》的灵感来自一个非凡的真实生活故事：《千击》的灵感来自声名狼藉的玛丽·卡尔（Mary Carr）的非凡真实生活故事，她领导了一个臭名昭著的伦敦全女性帮派——四十大盗（Forty Elephants）。由于本周是国际妇女节，我们觉得我们应该讨论的，不一定是历史上最臭名昭著的女性，而是其中一些最非凡的女性，不是吗，多米尼克？确实如此。所以我不确定你的选择是谁，汤姆，但我们在《历史的 rest》中讨论过的那个人
Today's episode is brought to you by a thousand blows. The new original series premiering exclusively on Disney plus. A thousand blows is inspired by the remarkable true life story of the Fires and Blows is inspired by the remarkable true life story of the infamous Mary Carr, who led a notorious all-female London gang, the Forty Elephants. And as it's International Women's Day this week, we thought we'd talk about not necessarily the most notorious women in history, but some of the most remarkable ones, didn't we, Dominic? We did indeed. So I don't know who yours is, Tom, but the person
我经常想起的是一个名叫索菲·绍尔（Sophie Scholl）的年轻女性，她在 20 世纪 30 年代末和 40 年代初在德国长大。她是一个非常认真且具有高度道德严肃性的年轻女性。她和她的哥哥汉斯加入并成为了一个名为“白玫瑰”组织（White Rose Group）的核心成员，该组织在德国各地分发小册子和传单，攻击第三帝国的罪行。正如你所记得的，汤姆，索菲迎来了非常悲惨的结局，她
who we've talked about in the rest of history that I often think about is a young woman called Sophie Scholl, who grew up in Germany in the late 1930s, early 1940s. And she was a young woman of enormous sort of earnestness and kind of moral seriousness. And she and her brother Hans joined and were key parts of an organization called the White Rose Group, which distributed pamphlets and leaflets across Germany, attacking the crimes of the Third Reich. And as you'll remember, Tom, Sophie came to a very sad end that they
和汉斯被捕，并遭到纳粹的审讯、审判和处决。关于她在施塔代尔海姆（Stadelheim）监狱里，以及死前最后几个小时的故事，她在祈祷，并且对挺身反对纳粹主义的恐怖毫无悔意，我认为这是整个历史（不仅仅是 20 世纪历史）中最具鼓舞人心的故事之一。是的，这是一个如此卓越的年轻女性。我选择了一位没有为自由而死，但她是一位非凡的足球运动员（如果你在美国观看这个节目，就是英式足球运动员）。她叫莉莉·帕尔（Lily Parr）。她于 1905 年出生在兰开夏郡的圣海伦斯。她来自一个庞大的家庭，有很多男孩。作为一个女孩，她非常喜欢橄榄球，尤其是足球。
were, she and Hans were captured and they were interrogated and tried and executed by the Nazis. And the story of her in prison in the Stadelheim prison, and the last hours before her death, and she's sort of praying and she's she's completely unapologetic about standing up against the horrors of Nazism, I think is one of the most inspirational stories in all history, not just in 20th century history. Yeah, such a remarkable young woman. I've chosen a young woman who didn't die for Liberty, but she was an extraordinary footballer or soccer player, if you're watching this in America. She was called Lily Parr. She was born in St. Helens in Lancashire in 1905. She was part of a huge family, lots of boys. And she, as a girl, loved playing rugby and particularly football.
当第一次世界大战袭击英国时，男足基本被取消了。于是每个人都开始改看女足。而莉莉是一名难以置信的优秀球员。所以当她 14 岁时，她被招募到一家名为迪克·科尔（Dick, Kerr's）的军火工厂踢球，当时她只有 14 岁，我在她的第一个赛季里她好像进了大约 100 个球，她从第一次世界大战一直踢到了第二次世界大战结束后。她以踢球的残酷性而闻名。据说她在主罚任意球时踢断了一个男人的腿，她还踢断了另一个男人的手臂，那时的足球非常非常重，所以她能
And when the first world war hit Britain, men's football basically got canceled. And so everyone started watching women's football instead. And Lily was an incredible, incredible player. So when she was 14, she got recruited to play for this munitions factory called Dick Kerz and she was only 14 and she scored I think something like 100 goals in her first season and she played right the way through the first World War into the aftermath of the Second World War. She was famous for the brutality of her kicking. She said to have broken the leg of one man when she took a free kick, she broke another man's arm and footballs then were really really heavy so for her
踢动它——绝对太惊人了。而让她的运动能力更加非凡的是，她喜欢抽烟，人们总能看到她牙齿间叼着一根伍德拜因（Woodbine）香烟，渐渐地她的牙齿都烂掉并脱落了。随着时间的推移，控制英格兰足球的男人们开始对女子球队的名气产生怨恨。因此，他们基本上禁止她们使用职业足球场。非常悲伤。
to kick it I mean absolutely amazing. And what made her sporting ability even more remarkable is that she loved smoking and she was never seen without a woodbine between her teeth and gradually her teeth all rotted and fell out. And in due course, the men who controlled football in England got resentful of the fame of the female teams. And so they basically banned them from using the professional football grounds. Very sad.
但是，因此莉莉退役了，她成为了一名护士，但她从未被遗忘，她现在被誉为英格兰不仅是最伟大的女运动员之一，也是有史以来最伟大的运动员之一，我想她是第一位入选英格兰足球名人堂的女性。所以，你知道我的意思——她虽然比不上索菲·绍尔，但她是一位非凡非凡的女性。这太棒了，不是吗，汤姆，像这样女性的故事正在被恢复到她们在近代历史中应有的地位。这也是我如此期待这个新系列的原因之一。
But, and so Lily retired and she became a nurse but she was never forgotten and she's now celebrated as one of England's not just greatest sportswomen but sportspeople of all time and I think that she was the first woman to be inducted into English football's hall of fame. So you know I mean she's not up there with Sophie Scholl but she was a remarkable remarkable woman. It's brilliant isn, I mean, she's not up there with Sophie Scholl, but she was a remarkable, remarkable woman. It's brilliant, isn't it, Tom, that women's stories like these are being restored to their proper place in recent history. And that's one reason I'm looking forward to this, to
所以这一段由我们在 Disney Plus 的朋友赞助播出。因此，《千击》是一部全新的原创剧集，目前正在全球 Disney Plus 上线流媒体播放，如果你在美国观看，它在 Hulu 上。欢迎回到《历史的 rest》，在休息前，汤姆向你们保证，他说他有很多关于那些争取全面政治权利的女性的资料。实际上，其中一位是节目的老朋友。
this new series so much. So this segment was brought to you by our friends at Disney Plus. So a thousand blows, that is a new original series and it is streaming right now on Disney Plus globally and if you're watching this in the US it is on Hulu. Welcome back to the rest is history before the break Tom promised you he said he'd got binders full of women who were pushing for full political rights. And actually one of them is an old friend of the show.
一个在妇女进军凡尔赛事件中非常突出、极具浮夸风采的了不起的人物，那就是泰鲁瓦涅·德·梅里库尔（Théroigne de Méricourt）。她腰间挂着手枪，看起来有点像海盗。她有一种——就像亚当一样——像亚当一样，是的，看起来很浪漫，没错。她戴着一顶自由帽。她有一顶华丽的帽子。她骑着马。形象非常引人注目，但实际上她随后陷入了一些麻烦，遇到了大麻烦。
So a tremendous character who was very prominent in the women's march on Versailles, cut a very flamboyant figure and that is Tejuan de Mericourt. So she had kind of pistols in a belt, she looked a bit like a pirate. She had a kind of, I don't's it Adam and like Adam and yeah, she look at you romantic exactly She had a kind of Liberty cap. She had a fancy hat She's on a horse Cut scrape figure but actually she then gets into a bit of a mess and she terrible scrape Yeah, a scrape is that what it is? It's a scrape. So she's captured by Austrian agents. Tell us about that.
是的，麻烦，是这样吗？是个大麻烦。所以她被奥地利特工俘虏了。给我们讲讲那个吧。
Well, because she's actually Belgian. So she's from Liège, which is under kind of Austrian ruled low countries. And May 1790, she goes there very ill advisedly, you know, to catch up with all her old friends. And she gets arrested by Austrian agents put into prison. And the Austrian see this as a great coup because she's notorious as a kind of revolutionary Amazon. And so this is a great prize and they transport her all the way to Austria where she is kept in prison for months and months. And she's finally released at the end of 1791 because rather sweetly her jailer has grown very fond of her. She seems to be a very kind of very charismatic person. And
嗯，因为她其实是比利时人。所以她来自列日（Liège），那是在奥地利统治下的低地国家。1790 年 5 月，她非常不明智地去了那里（你知道的，去见她所有的老朋友）。结果她被奥地利特工逮捕并投入监狱。奥地利人认为这是一个巨大的政变，因为她作为一名革命亚马逊人而臭名昭著。因此这是一个巨大的战利品，他们一路把她押送到奥地利，在那里她被关在监狱里长达数月之久。最终在 1791 年底她被释放，因为非常讨人喜欢的是，她的狱卒对她产生了深厚的感情。她似乎是一个非常有魅力的人。
the jailer had obviously developed a bit of a shine for her. And so she then gets released and goes back to Paris. And of course, her role in the Women's March has now been supplemented by the fact that she's been imprisoned by Austrian despots. I mean, you couldn't have a kind of better calling card really. And so this gives her a stature among revolutionary men as a hero of the revolution that I think no other woman can rival because she's been there. She's done the hard yards. She's got the notches in her escutcheon to show that she's really served the revolution. And so even before her imprisonment, she had spoken at the Cordelia Club, which is the
这位狱卒显然对她颇有好感。随后她获释回到了巴黎。当然，她因曾被奥地利暴君监禁，在妇女进军中的角色如今更添光彩。我的意思是，这简直是再好不过的招牌了。因此，她在革命男性中树立了革命英雄的威望，我想这是其他任何女性都无法匹敌的，因为她亲历了这一切。她付出了艰辛的努力。她身上的累累战功表明，她确实为革命出过力。因此，甚至在她入狱之前，她就在科德利埃俱乐部（Cordelia Club）发表过演讲，该俱乐部是
most radical of all the clubs. And after it, she is allowed to come and give an account of what she'd been getting up to in prison and everything at the Jacquemint Club itself. So these are very, very distinctive, almost kind of unprecedented markers of her status. But I think the very taste of what it would be to be a kind of political player, to be not just a spectator at these clubs, but a participant makes it all the more frustrating for her that women are essentially kept out of that, that they're not allowed to do it. And so she pursues a policy of trying to, to counter that. So she attempts to found, um, women's only clubs, uh, mixed clubs, but it doesn't
所有俱乐部中最激进的一个。事后，她被允许前往雅各宾俱乐部（Jacquemint Club）本身，讲述她在狱中的种种经历。因此，这些是非常非常独特的、几乎可以说是前所未有的地位标志。但我觉得，正是这种亲身体验政治玩家滋味的契机——不仅是这些俱乐部的旁观者，而是成为参与者——让她对女性基本上被排斥在外、不被允许参与的现状感到更加沮丧。因此，她奉行了一套试图对抗这种现象的政策。于是她尝试创立纯女性俱乐部、
work. Um, and it largely doesn't work because women don't really seem to have wanted to participate in them. And then in 1792, she gives up on the whole, you know, sitting around and talking because of course she's very much a woman for a pistol in a belt. And so with Paris being threatened, she agitates for a woman's battalion to be set up to help in the defense of Paris. And again, this is turned down. When the attack on the Tuileries happens, the attack that results in the massacre of the Swiss guards. She's there, she's all over it. It's very much her scene, kind of brandishing pistols again. And for this, she receives public honor.
混合俱乐部，但都没能成功。嗯，而且大体上失败的原因在于，女性似乎并不怎么愿意参与其中。接着在1792年，她彻底放弃了那种“坐而论道”的想法，因为她本来就是个腰间别着手枪的性格刚烈的女性。因此，在巴黎受到威胁时，她积极奔走，呼吁组建一支女子营来协助保卫巴黎。然而，这一提议再次遭到拒绝。当杜伊勒里宫遭遇袭击——那场导致瑞士卫队大屠杀的袭击——发生时，她就在现场，全程参与其中。这完全是她的作风，再次挥舞着手枪。为此，她受到了公众的表彰。
But I think that she remains an anomaly because she's taught between the traditional dimensions of the masculine and the feminine, the kind of the active and the domestic, the political and the person who stays at home fostering and looking after the people who will engage in politics, namely men. And in due course, as we will see, because we'll continue her story in subsequent episodes, this tension, it ends up destroying her. So just before you move on to the other person you want to talk about, there are other people who agree with her, other women who agree with her and say, especially when war is declared,
但我认为她依然是一个特例，因为她夹在男性与女性的传统维度之间：积极与持家、政治与留守家中培育和照顾那些将要从事政治活动的人（即男性）之间。正如我们将要看到的，随着我们在后续剧集中继续讲述她的故事，这种张力最终将她毁灭。所以在你转向你要谈论的另一个人之前，还有其他人赞同她，有其他女性赞同她，并表示，特别是在宣战之后，
they want to join the war effort. So there are two sisters called the Fernig sisters who took up arms in the defense of Valenciennes in the east of France. The general was so impressed by them, he promised to put them in the line of fire at the first opportunity. And then there's a petition put up by an activist called Pauline Layon, which was read out to the Legislative Assembly. So this is summer 1792. Our fathers, husbands and sons may perhaps be the victims of Erinamys' fury. Could we be forbidden the sweetness of avenging them
她们想要加入战争。因此有两姐妹，被称为费尔尼格（Fernig）姐妹，她们在法国东部的瓦朗谢讷（Valenciennes）拿起武器参与了保卫战。将军对她们印象深刻，并承诺一有机会就安排她们上火线。接着，一位名叫保琳·莱翁（Pauline Layon）的活动人士发起了一份请愿书，并在立法议会上被宣读。这是在1792年夏天。我们的父亲、丈夫和儿子或许会成为厄里倪厄斯（Erinamys）狂怒的牺牲品。难道我们会被剥夺复仇的甜蜜，
or dying at their sides? You cannot refuse us. Society cannot deny us this right which is given us by nature unless it's claimed that the Declaration of Rights does not apply to women. And the Legislative Assembly, you know what it does? It just ignores them because people are embarrassed. And actually in April 1793, the convention bans women, officially bans them from going into battle. But that issue of the Declaration of Rights brings us to the other great character that you're going to talk about today, who is a great favourite of mine and her name is Olip de Gouge. So tell us about her. I mean, I think you're absolutely right
或是在他们身旁死去的权力吗？你们不能拒绝我们。社会不能剥夺大自然赋予我们的这项权利，除非有人宣称《人权宣言》不适用于女性。而立法议会，你知道它是怎么做的吗？它只是选择无视，因为大家觉得很尴尬。实际上，在1793年4月，国民公会颁布禁令，正式禁止女性上战场。但《人权宣言》这个议题，把我们引向了你今天要谈论的另一位伟大人物——她是我非常喜欢的一位，名叫奥兰普·德古热（Olympe de Gouges）。那么，给我们讲讲她吧。我的意思是，我认为你说得完全没错：
that there are women who, listening to the revolutionary rhetoric, the talk about the rights of men, draw the logical conclusion and say, well, if men have rights, why don't women? And as you said, war seems to have been a particular focus for this, the idea that men should defend the country. If men can defend it, why not women? And there are those who want to do that. But equally, the revolutionary authorities regard it as an embarrassment. They don't really want to give any encouragement to it. And that's why nothing really comes of it. There is no revolutionary battalion of Amazons defending the patrie
有些女性在聆听了革命 rhetoric（修辞）、关于人权的言论后，得出了合乎逻辑的结论，她们说，既然男人有权利，为什么女性没有呢？正如你所说，战争似乎是这方面的一个核心焦点，即男人应该保卫国家。如果男人能保卫国家，为什么女人不能？确实有人想要这么做。但同样地，革命当局认为这是一件尴尬的事。他们其实不想对此给予任何鼓励。正因如此，这件事最终不了了之。并没有出现由亚马逊女战士组成的革命营来保卫祖国
on the barricades. And it's left to one woman in particular to hammer home for what I think clearly from our perspective seems a monstrous unfairness. And as you said, this is this is a limp to go a woman who is becoming I think better known pretty much by the year, would you say? Yeah, that's no now than she's ever been, I would say. And that is because more than anybody else in the revolution, she is exposing this key hypocrisy. If there are rights of men, then why not rights of women? And she is, I think, a very attractive figure. I mean, literally attractive. She's very charming, described in 1770 as one of Paris's prettiest women, but she's just
的街垒。最终，这一切落在一个特定女性的身上，由她来大声疾呼，揭露在我们看来显然极其不公的事实。正如你所说，这位德古热女士，随着时间的推移，现在可以说是越来越出名了，你觉得呢？是的，比起以往任何时候，她现在都更有名气。这是因为，在革命中，没有人比她更赤裸裸地暴露了这种核心伪善。既然有人权，为什么就没有女权呢？而且我认为她是一个非常迷人的形象。字面意义上的迷人。她非常富有魅力，在1770年被描述为巴黎最漂亮的女性之一，但她同时
also her personality is very appealing. She's kind of witty. She's I mean, she seems fun. I think that's probably the best way to describe it. And she's born in the Long Dock, but she comes to Paris in 1768 when she is 20 years old. And she does so initially as the mistress of a wealthy industrialist from Lyon. There is all kinds of gossip in Paris that she is a courtesan. So there is a paper called La Correspondance, who writes in 1770, so two years after her appearance in Paris, that she's born with a pretty face as her
性格也非常讨人喜欢。她很机智。我的意思是，她看起来很有趣。我想这可能是最好的形容方式了。她出生在朗格多克（Long Dock），但在1768年20岁时来到了巴黎。她最初是以里昂一位富有实业家的情妇身份来到这里的。巴黎当时到处都有传言说她是个交际花。因此，有一份名为《通讯报》（La Correspondance）的报纸在1770年（即她出现在巴黎两年后）写道，她生来只有一张漂亮的脸蛋作为唯一的
only heritage. She is known in Paris for sometimes solely through the favors with which she gratifies her compatriots. And one of these compatriots, it was rumored was Dominic, your old friend, the Duke of Orleans, Philippe Egalité. Truly terrible man. With whom she was supposed to have had an affair, whether she had an affair with him or not, she was definitely part of his circle and she goes to the Palais Royal, which people may remember is this
遗产。她在巴黎广为人知，有时完全是因为她取悦同胞所获得的好感。传闻中她的其中一位同胞就是多米尼克，你的老朋友，奥尔良公爵（Duke of Orleans）菲利普·平等（Philippe Égalité）。一个真正可怕的人。人们传说她曾与这位公爵有过一段绯闻。不管她有没有跟他有过风流韵事，她确实是其朋友圈的一员，并且她经常前往王宫（Palais Royal）。人们可能还记得，这是
kind of great complex of buildings in the centre of Paris, owned by the Duke of Orléans, which in the pre-revolutionary world was a kind of place of free thinking. Anything could be published there, anything could be said, and this is the world into which Olympe de Gouges moves and she becomes a kind of leading contributor to it. She's fascinated by it. She is obsessed by all the ideas and the currents of conversation, the politics there. And what's amazing about this is that her background is actually unbelievably poor. She derived in Paris barely able to read or write.
巴黎市中心的一组宏伟建筑群，归奥尔良公爵所有。在革命前的世界里，这里是一个崇尚自由思想的地方。任何东西都可以在那里出版，任何观点都可以在那里发表。这就是奥兰普·德古热所融入的世界，并成为了其中的主要撰稿人之一。她对此着迷不已。她痴迷于那里所有的思想、对话潮流以及政治氛围。而令人惊叹的是，她的出身其实穷得难以想象。她刚到巴黎时，几乎不识字。
I mean, much debate among scholars as to whether she could read or write at all. And on top of that, French wasn't even her first language. She spoke Occitan. So she would have liked Marianne. Yeah, she would. Exactly. Her background is absolutely full of kind of the melodrama that you get in novels of this period. So the identity of her father is very mysterious. On the birth certificate
关于她当时到底会不会识字，学者们之间有很多争论。最重要的是，法语甚至都不是她的母语。她说的其实是奥克语（Occitan）。所以她会喜欢玛丽安娜（Marianne）。是的，她会的。完全正确。她的背景充满了那个时期小说中常见的各种情节剧色彩。所以她父亲的身份非常神秘。出生证明上
says that she's the daughter of a butcher, but there's much controversy about this. She liked to hint that she was the daughter of a marquis. At times she might even hint that she was the daughter of the king. So great kind of excitement and swirl of melodrama there. And she had then been forced into marriage at a very young age to a man she absolutely hated and who again in a very melodramatic way drowned in a flood. And this is what enabled her then to reject any prospect of future marriage she hated. The institution of marriage condemned it as a form of slavery and to come to Paris. I mean, clearly as a CET woman, but maybe a courtesan as well. But she is very, very smart. And this woman who, when she arrived in Paris, could barely read or write, she very quickly
说她是一个屠夫的女儿，但这引发了许多争议。她喜欢暗示自己是一位侯爵的女儿。有时她甚至暗示自己是国王的女儿。因此这里面充满了各种兴奋和戏剧化的漩涡。她随后在很年轻的时候就被迫嫁给了一个她绝对痛恨的男人，而这个男人又以一种极具戏剧性的方式在洪水中溺亡了。正是这一点让她得以拒绝任何她所痛恨的未来婚姻前景。她痛恨婚姻制度，将其谴责为一种奴隶制，并来到了巴黎。我的意思是，显然她是一位丧偶的女性，但可能也是一名交际花。不过她非常非常聪明。这位刚到巴黎时几乎不识字的女性，很快
becomes not just a kind of a participant in intellectual debate, but she becomes first of all a novelist and then a playwright. So she writes her first novel in 17 debate, but she becomes first of all a novelist and then a playwright. So she writes her first novel in 1784, then gets very into the theatre. She becomes a friend of Sebastien Mercier, who we talked about in the previous episode, that playwright who came up with all the horrific details about the death of the Princess de la Bal. And her most famous play is called Les Clavage denoir the slavery of the blacks is a very ripe melodrama about a young girl being reunited with her long lost father. So Olymp de Gouges clearly working issues out there, but it is also very, very vehemently
就不仅成为了辩论的参与者，而且先是成为了一名小说家，接着又成为了一名剧作家。因此她在1784年写下了第一部小说，然后深深迷上了戏剧。她成为了塞巴斯蒂安·梅尔西（Sebastien Mercier）的朋友——我们在上一集中提到过他，那位剧作家曾讲述了关于德朗巴尔公主（Princess de la Bal）之死的种种恐怖细节。她最著名的戏剧名为《黑人的奴役》（L'Esclavage des Noirs），这是一部非常成熟的情节剧，讲述了一个年轻女孩与失散多年的父亲重聚的故事。所以奥兰普·德古热显然在其中探讨了很多社会议题，但它也是一部非常非常激进的
abolitionist. So she is hugely opposed to the slave trade and the impact of this play is such that the slave trade lobby pay hecklers to go to the theatre and to shout it down and such is the kind of the uproar that this generates that the play can only be staged for three nights and it has to be withdrawn which is obviously you know on one level very bad for Olymp de Gouges. She wants the message to get out there. She's going to miss out on the money that she would otherwise have earned, but it does make her famous. It makes her a figure of prestige and status in the intellectual world of pre-revolutionary Paris. And by and large, I think it's fair to say that anyone who is a committed abolitionist
废奴主义作品。因此她强烈反对奴隶贸易，这部剧产生的影响之大，以至于奴隶贸易游说集团花钱雇了起哄者去剧院大喊大叫，将其嘘下台。这种抗议引发了巨大的轰动，导致该剧仅上演了三个晚上就被迫下架。这在某种层面上对奥兰普·德古热来说显然是非常糟糕的。她希望自己的信息能够传达出去，而且她也将失去原本可以赚到的版税，但这确实让她出了名。这让她在革命前巴黎的知识界成为一个享有威望和地位的人物。总的来说，我认为可以公平地说，任何在革命前就坚定致力于废奴的人，
before the revolution, when the revolution comes, is pretty much bound to be in favor of it. Yeah, of course. And Olymp de Gouges, she's a big fan of the revolution. But with caveats, right? Yeah, quite a kind of idiosyncratic take on it. So she always has a very soft spot for Louis XVI. And again, it may be this thing she identifies with Louis the 16th as a man who's unfortunate in his parents. Yeah,
当革命到来时，几乎注定会支持它。是的，当然。而奥兰普·德古热，她是革命的狂热支持者。但也是有条件的，对吧？是的，她对此有着非常独特的看法。因此她对路易十六总是抱有一丝温情。同样，这可能是因为她将自己与路易十六联系在了一起，认为他是一个在父母问题上不太走运的人。是的，
a bit like she was with her father. Maybe she's really his daughter after all. Well, I think I think she was meant to be the the daughter of of Louis the 15th. All right. So she says, but what does that make her his Steps sister step sister. Yeah, yeah Sister half sister. Oh, no, it's too complicated. I can't work it out But anyway, so she feels that Louis 16th has been dealt a very bad hand by his predecessors by Louis the 15th The people have gone before and so she wrote about him an unhappier king than his ancestors Is he to be made responsible for their mistakes? So right the way through everything that follows the fall of the Bastille, right the way up to the flight to Varenne when Louis XVI and
有点像她和她父亲的关系。也许她真的是他的私生女呢。好吧，我想她本该是路易十五的女儿。好吧。所以她说，那这让她成了他的什么人？继姐？继姐。对，对。同父异母的姐姐。哦，不，这太复杂了。我理不清了。不过总之，她觉得路易十六被他的前任们——路易十五以及那些在她之前的人——发了一手烂牌。所以她为他写道：“比起他的祖先，这是一个更不幸的国王，难道要让他为他们的错误负责吗？”因此，从巴士底狱陷落之后的整个过程，一直到路易十六和
the royal family tried to escape Paris and France, she's very, very, you know, always sticking up for him. When he makes his flight to Varenne, she's very, very disappointed in him. Yeah, Understandably. She feels that, you know, he's let her down. He's let France down, but worst of all, he's let himself down. Yeah. But she still feels sorry for him. And I think that's reflective of the fact that above all, she has, she has a big heart, Dominic. She feels the sufferings of others deeply. Yeah. So whether it's the, you know, slaves in the Caribbean, whether it's the poor, whether it's the king, whether it's animals, she's a great animal lover, you know, she, she feels compassion for them all.
王室试图逃离巴黎和法国的瓦雷讷之逃（Flight to Varenne），她始终都在坚定地支持他。当路易十六出逃瓦雷讷时，她对他感到非常非常失望。是的，可以理解。她觉得，他让她失望了，让法国失望了，但最糟糕的是，他让自己失望了。是的。但她仍然对感到他同情。我认为这反映了一个事实，即最重要的是，她有一颗宽广的心，多米尼克。她对别人的痛苦有着深刻的共情。是的。所以无论是加勒比海的奴隶，还是穷人，无论是国王，还是动物——她是个伟大的动物爱好者——你知道，她对所有人都能抱有同情心。
That's lovely. We love somebody with a big heart. So I think that this explains why she comes to feel as she does about the revolution, just as the king has let her down. So she feels that the revolution is letting her down. So people may remember, I can't even remember which episode it was now, we've done so many episodes on the revolution, but back in 1791, France gets its first written constitution. This is the one that Louis XVI had been trying not to sign and eventually he kind of feels bulldozed into doing it.
这太美好了。我们都爱心胸宽广的人。所以我想这就解释了为什么她对革命会有那样的感受，正如国王让她失望一样。所以她觉得革命也让她失望了。大家可能还记得，我现在甚至记不清那是哪一集了，我们关于革命做了这么多的节目，早在1791年，法国就有了第一部成文宪法。这就是路易十六一直试图拒绝签署、最后却感到被强行逼迫而不得不签的那部宪法。
And it passes into law on the 3rd of September 1791. Louis XVI accepts it 10 days later. This is now the constitution that is going to govern France. And this is the one that offers a measure of suffrage to men, but not to women. And Olymp de Gouges is appalled by this. And she says, well, what about women? Why shouldn't women have the vote? Why shouldn't women have rights as well? And so 12 days later on the 15th of September, she, you know, she's written this riposte and she publishes it and it's called very pointedly, the Declaration of the Rights of Woman and of the Female Citizen. So it's an obvious parody, the Declaration of the Rights of Woman and of the Female Citizen.
它于1791年9月3日正式成为法律。路易十六在十天后接受了它。这就是将要统治法国的宪法。而这部宪法赋予了男性一定程度的选举权，却没有赋予女性。奥兰普·德古热对此感到震惊。她说道：“女性怎么办？为什么女性不该拥有选举权？为什么女性不该同样享有权利？”因此，12天后的9月15日，她写下了这篇反驳之作并将其发表，其标题非常切中要害，叫做《女权与女公民权利宣言》（Declaration of the Rights of Woman and of the Female Citizen）。所以它显然是对《人权和公民权宣言》的戏仿。这就是《女权与女公民权利宣言》。
So it's an obvious parody of the Declaration of the Rights of Man and the Citizen. And it's a marker of her, again, yeah, idiosyncratic take on politics that she dedicates this to Marie Antoinette. That's the last person that you will choose, right? If you were worried about your standing in revolutionary Paris. It's simultaneously a kind of parody of revolutionary idealism, but also I think it's ultimate expression. Because by echoing the original declaration, she's aiming to remind the world what it's missing. So woman is born free and is equal to man in her rights. She's
所以这显然是对《人权和公民权宣言》的恶搞。这也标志着她——再次强调，她对政治有着独特的看法——将这份宣言献给了玛丽·安托瓦内特。如果你担心自己在革命巴黎的地位，这绝对是你最不会选择的人！这既是对革命理想主义的一种讽刺，但同时我也认为这是其极致的表达。因为通过呼应最初的宣言，她的目的是提醒世界它所缺失的是什么。所以，“女人生来自由，在权利上与男人平等”。她
deliberately parodying the phrases of the Declaration of the Rights of Man. And she is demanding that women share in all these rights, which of course includes suffrage. And she articulates this in a very famous way and one that looks forward notoriously to what is to happen in 1793. When she writes, woman has the right to climb onto the scaffold, she must equally have the right to climb onto the tribunal. So in other words, if she can be executed, then she should have the right to govern the laws, to vote. Grimly ironic words. to govern the laws to vote. Grimly ironic words.
故意模仿《人权宣言》的句式。并且她要求女性分享所有这些权利，当然这其中也包括选举权。她以一种非常著名的方式表达了这一点，这一表述也臭名昭著地预示了1793年将要发生的事情。当她写道：“女性有权走上断头台，她就同样有权走上议会讲台。”换句话说，既然她能被处决，那么她就应该有权参与制定法律、享有投票权。充满阴暗讽刺意味的话语。参与制定法律、享有投票权。充满阴暗讽刺意味的话语。
Very grimly ironic. Now, what is the response to this declaration of the rights of women? There are certainly revolutionaries who accept male revolutionaries who accept its force. The most prominent of these is the erstwhile Marquis de Condorcet, who we met again ages ago. He's a philosopher, kind of enlightenment, philosoph, very very anti-Christian. He's an economist. He's very agitated by polluted rivers. And like Olymp de Gouges, he's a very committed abolitionist. So all reasons why he would
非常阴暗的讽刺。那么，对于这份《女权宣言》，各方的反应如何呢？确实有革命者、男性革命者接受了它的合理性。其中最突出的就是前侯爵孔多塞（Condorcet）——我们很久以前见过他。他是一位哲学家，启蒙思想家（philosophe），极其反基督教。他是一位经济学家。他对受污染的河流感到非常焦虑。和奥兰普·德古热一样，他也是一位坚定的废奴主义者。所有这些原因都说明他会
be sympathetic to what she's arguing. And he absolutely supports female suffrage. And I think it's not just Olymp de Gouges who is kind of influencing him on this. It's also his own wife who is a very, very impressive woman called Sophie de Grouchy, who is sister of a guy who will in due course become one of Napoleon's most celebrated marshals, Emmanuel de Grouchy. Now we've had quite a lot of relationships in this series and indeed in the rest of history generally where the man is quite a lot older than the woman. So the age gap between Condorcet and Sophie is 20. So she marries him when he's 22 and he's 42, but it's a very happy
对她的观点抱有同情。并且他完全支持女性选举权。而且我认为不仅是奥兰普·德古热在这一点上影响了他，还有他自己的妻子，一位非常非常了不起的女性，名叫苏菲·德·格鲁希（Sophie de Grouchy）。她是后来成为拿破仑最著名元帅之一的伊曼纽尔·德·格鲁希（Emmanuel de Grouchy）的姐姐。我们在本系列节目中以及整个人类历史上，都见过不少男方比女方大很多的伴侣。孔多塞和苏菲的年龄差距是20岁。所以她嫁给他时他22岁（编者注：应为42岁），但这是一段非常美满的
match. They're both philosophers. So you can imagine, you know, they have a lovely time sitting around discussing Diderot or Rousseau or whatever. And she's also very skilled linguist and Dominic, the tremendous news is that her best second language is English. Good for her. She translates Adam Smith.
婚姻。他们都是哲学家。所以你可以想象，他们坐在那里讨论狄德罗（Diderot）、卢梭（Rousseau）或诸如此类的话题，度过了非常美好的时光。她还是一位极具才华的语言学家，多米尼克，有个好得惊人的消息是，她第二好的语言是英语。真不简单。她翻译了亚当·斯密。
Yeah. Tremendous. And Thomas Paine. And she actually runs a salon. Unlike Madame Roulon, she allows other women to come to her salon. Including Olymp Tremendous. And Thomas Payne. And she actually runs a salon. Unlike Madame Roland, she allows other women to come to her salon. Including Olympe de Gouges. So that's where they would all have met. Right. Yeah. And the Condors say they're not kind of card carrying Girondins, but they're definitely aligned with them. And I think it's true to
太棒了。还有托马斯·潘恩。她甚至还经营着一个沙龙。与罗兰夫人不同，她允许其他女性来到她的沙龙。其中包括奥兰普 太棒了。还有托马斯·潘恩。她甚至还经营着一个沙龙。与罗兰夫人不同，她允许其他女性来到她的沙龙。其中包括奥兰普·德古热。所以这就是他们所有人相聚的地方。没错。是的。孔多塞夫妇虽然不是那种持党员证的吉伦特派，但他们绝对与吉伦特派立场一致。而且我认为可以这样说，吉伦特派比山岳派要更加支持女性参与公共生活。因此，尽管罗兰夫人是一位吉伦特派，但她并不……这其实是吉伦特派沙龙内部知识分子讨论的一部分，特别是孔多塞的沙龙，即女性或许应该拥有选举权。所以奥兰普·德古热认为吉伦特派很棒，这也就不足为奇了。她称他们为“自由的保卫者”……等等。她也将自己与吉伦特派联系在一起。但总的来说，必须指出的是，对于《女权宣言》的反应——当人们还有心思去回应它的时候——要么是哄堂大笑，要么就是彻底的蔑视。有趣的是，那些更激进的雅各宾派、山岳派，比如罗伯
say that the Girondins are much more in favor of female participation in public life than the Montagnard. So even though Madame Roland, she's a Girondin, she's not. It is a kind of part of intellectual discussion among Girondins Salon, and particularly Condorcet Salon, that perhaps there should be female suffrage. And so it's not surprising that Olympe de Gouges, she thinks the Girondins are great. She calls them tortures of liberty, Terrande de Mericot. She also aligns herself with the, the, the Girondins. But in general, it has to be said that the reaction to the declaration of the rights of women, when people can be bothered so much as to respond to it is either hilarity or just utter contempt. And isn't it interesting that the more hardcore Jacqueman, the Montagnards, they call Rob
吉伦特派比山岳派更加支持女性参与公共生活。因此，尽管罗兰夫人是吉伦特派，但她并不算。在吉伦特派的沙龙中，尤其是孔多塞的沙龙里，这是一种知识分子讨论的一部分，即女性或许应该拥有选举权。因此，奥兰普·德古热认为吉伦特派很伟大也就不足为奇了。她称他们为自由的缔造者。她也将自己与吉伦特派结盟。但总的来说，必须指出的是，对于《女性权利宣言》的反应——当人们费心去回应它时——要么是狂笑，要么是彻底的蔑视。有趣的是，那些更激进的雅各宾派、山岳派，他们称罗布
Speer and his circle, people like that, they're often among the most contemptuous and the most scornful. And you would think in other respects, I mean, it's a really good example, I guess, of the, what some listeners may say is the kind of the patriarchal attitudes, the misogyny that in other respects, they are so democratic, but on this issue, they say women, are you joking? I mean, ha ha ha, women voting, wouldn't that be a great, wouldn't that be a thing? Yeah. And these are the people who, of course, you know, they're all in favor of Saint-Colott wearing the Liberty cap, the Bonnet Rouge, and indeed of the female representative of
斯庇尔和他的核心圈子，像这样的人，往往是最轻蔑、最嘲弄的人。你可能会在其他方面觉得，我想，这是一个很好的例子，对某些听众来说，这可能体现了一种父权态度和厌女症，即他们在其他方面如此民主，但在这个问题上，他们却说：‘女人？开什么玩笑？’我是说，哈哈，女人投票，难道这不是个好主意、难道这不是一回事吗？是的。这些人当然都支持无套裤汉戴上自由之帽、红色的无套裤汉帽，甚至支持
the Republic, Liberty, the future Marianne wearing the Liberty cap, but not actual women. They try and legislate to stop women from wearing it. And their justification for this, it's not just the Spartans, it's not just the Romans. There are also more recent influences of whom the main ones are the philosophes, so Diderot, but particularly Rousseau. Yeah. I mean, Rousseau has an incredible vein of hostility to any notion of female emancipation, of female suffrage. He wrote in his novel, which was a massive bestseller, La Nouvelle Eloise, a brilliant wife is a plague to her husband, her children, her friends, her valet, everyone. And Rousseau is such a massive influence on the way that
的各种主张充满了极度的敌意。他在自己那本超级畅销的小说《新爱洛伊丝》（La Nouvelle Héloïse）中写道：“一个精明的妻子对她的丈夫、她的孩子、她的朋友、她的仆人乃至所有人来说都是一场灾难。”而卢梭对年轻的男性革命者思考方式的影响是如此巨大，以至于他仿佛赋予了他们一种制裁的权力，让他们去庆祝一种极具男性气概的美德理想。当然，正如我们之前所说，这些人全都浸淫于罗马文学之中。所以他们知道“美德”（virtue）这个词本身就源自拉丁语的“男人”（virtus），意指拥有男性的品质。当这些年轻的革命者在模仿罗马人时——我们在前一集中讨论过这一点——扮演罗马人往往需要将一种男性的美德与女性的缺陷进行对照。因此，大画家大卫（David）在1789年画了一幅布鲁图斯（Brutus）的画，这位驱逐了国王、作为罗马共和国奠基人的男性。在这幅画中，这位男士神情严峻、坚定不移、为了自由的伟大事业铁石心肠。与此同时，在背景中，女人们却在歇斯底里、尖叫发狂，整体上一片大乱。男人的职责是将祖国（patry）放在首位，然后才是家庭。女人的职责则是留在家庭内部，抚养能够出去为祖国效力的公民。我的意思是，你可以把“patry”翻译为祖国或父国，对吧？完全可以。
particularly young male revolutionaries think that he kind of provides them with a sanction for kind of celebrating a very overtly masculine ideal of virtue. And of course, you know, as we've said earlier, these are all people who are saturated in Roman literature. So they know that the word virtue itself derives from the Latin for man, virtus is to have masculine qualities. And when these young revolutionaries are playing the Roman, we talked about this in an earlier episode, to play the Roman often requires a counterpointing of a kind of masculine virtue against a female inadequacy. So David, the great painter in 1789, he does a painting of Brutus, the man who expelled the king, the kind of the
特别是年轻的男性革命者，认为他赋予了他们一种认可，去庆祝一种非常公开的阳刚之气的美德理想。当然，正如我们之前所说，这些人都是浸润在罗马文学中的。因此他们知道，“美德”这个词本身源自拉丁语中的“男人”，virtus 就是具备男性的品质。当这些年轻的我们在之前的节目中讨论过时，扮演罗马人通常需要将一种阳刚的美德与女性的不足进行对比。因此，伟大画家大卫在1789年画了一幅布鲁图斯的画，布鲁图斯是驱逐国王的人，也就是
founder of the Roman Republic. And in this painting, the man is shown stern, unyielding, flinty in the cause of liberty. And meanwhile, in the background, you have women having the vapors. They're kind of in hysterics, kind of screaming and generally losing the plot. And it is the role of the man to put the patry first, then the family. It is the role of the woman to stay within the domestic household and to raise citizens who can then go out and play their part serving the patry. I mean, you could translate patry, right, as homeland or as fatherland, couldn't you? You absolutely could.
罗马共和国的缔造者。在这幅画中，这个男人显得严厉、坚定、为了自由的事业铁石心肠。与此同时，在背景中，女人们却情绪激动、歇斯底里、尖叫并且彻底失控。男人的职责是将祖国放在首位，然后才是家庭。女人的职责则是留在家庭内部，培养能够出去为祖国效力的公民。我的意思是，“patrie”这个词，你可以把它翻译成“祖国”或“父国”，对吧？完全可以。
Yeah. And so it for men, radicals, even those on, or maybe especially those on the furthest left, it's this combination, this fusion of the ancient and the cutting edge that serves to justify them in their, well, yeah, I mean, their contempt for everything that Olymp de Gouges is arguing for. But I think the thing that's unsettling perhaps for us today, and certainly for many of the feminist scholars that I read on this, is that it's not just men who are thinking this, a majority of women seem to have thought so too. And Contour say, who's in favor of female suffrage, he's really puzzled by it.
是的。因此对于激进的男性来说，即使是那些处于最左翼、或者也许正是那些处于最左翼的人，正是这种古代与前沿思想的结合与融合，构成了他们对奥兰普·德古热所主张的一切抱持蔑视的正当理由。但我想，今天对我们而言、以及对许多研究这一课题的女权主义学者而言，最令人不安的是，不仅仅是男性这样想，绝大多数女性似乎也持相同的看法。而支持女性选举权的孔多塞对此感到非常困惑。
And he's one of the people who watches women idolizing Robespierre, who's absolutely against female suffrage. And he's kind of really puzzled by it. And he's one of the people who watches women idolizing Robespierre, who's absolutely against female suffrage. And he's kind of really puzzled by it. And so he writes, one wonders sometimes why there are so many women following Robespierre at his home, at the podium of the Jacobin, at the Cordelia, at the convention. And he says, which is absolutely right, well, maybe one reason for this is that women are reading Rousseau too. And La Nouvelle Eloise, his great novel, I mean, that are reading Russo too. And la nouvelle Eloise is great novel. I mean, that's a massive with women. So maybe they're imbibing it. Um, so Madame Roland is a big fan of Russo, uh, Rosalie Julien, who you
他也是那些看到女性盲目崇拜坚决反对女性选举权的罗伯斯庇尔的人之一，对此他感到十分不解。因此他写道：“人们有时会奇怪，为什么有那么多女性追随罗伯斯庇尔，无论是在他的家中、雅各宾俱乐部的讲台上、科德利埃俱乐部，还是在国民公会上。”并且他指出（这完全正确）：“或许原因之一在于，女性也在阅读卢梭的书。”而他的伟大小说《新爱洛伊丝》在女性中大受欢迎。所以也许她们深受其影响。嗯，罗兰夫人是卢梭的超级粉丝，我们在上一集引用的罗莎莉·朱利安（Rosalie Julien）也是如此。嗯，她也是卢梭的狂热粉丝。所以，也许就是这个原因，但、但我真的很难相信仅此而已。
were quoting in the previous episode. Um, I mean, she was a big fan of Russo. So, I mean, maybe it's that, but I, I mean, I can't really believe that that's. It's not just that there is a, so if you think a hundred years hence, when there are going to be huge arguments about women voting, often among the most vociferous opponents of it are other women, you know, opposing suffrage campaigns, not just in France, in Britain, in the United States, wherever. And don't historians think that effectively a lot of women had internalized the assumptions of the age, that they have come to believe, they come to believe what they're told, that
不仅如此，如果你想想一百年后，当关于女性投票权的巨大争论爆发时，其中最激烈的反对者往往也是其他女性，她们反对争取选举权的运动，无论是在法国、英国、美国还是其他地方。难道历史学家们不认为，实际上许多女性已经内化了那个时代的假设，她们开始相信、并坚信她们被灌输的观念——
they have their domestic sphere, which is their domain, and that there is the public sphere, which is the domain of men. I think it's this language of rights, perhaps, that underpins it, which Olymp de Gouges is drawing on. But it also applies to men. So one of the striking things about this election to the convention, which is it's the first really full male suffrage in any election. I think our perspective today would be people denied a right to vote would embrace it. You know,
即她们拥有属于她们的主权领域——家庭领域，而公共领域则是属于男性的领域吗？我认为这背后或许是由奥兰普·德古热所借鉴的那种“权利”话语所支撑的。但这同样适用于男性。因此，关于国民公会的这次选举，有一个引人注目的事实，这是任何选举中首次真正意义上的全男性普选。我想我们今天的视角会认为，被剥夺投票权的人一旦获得权利就会欣然接受。你知道，
they would feel that a great weight had been lifted off their shoulders, that a great injustice had been righted. But what's striking about that election is how few people participate in it. I think it's something like one in six. Yeah, maybe one in 10. That must reflect maybe a bewilderment, a puzzlement, simply an inability to understand what's being offered on the part of men who are being given this right. And presumably then the same would be true of women. This is such a kind of novel way of understanding politics and the role of individuals within a polity, the people just can't get a handle on it.
他们会觉得自己卸下了肩上的重担，一大冤屈得到了平反。但那次选举中最令人瞩目的，是参与的人数竟是如此之少。我想大概是六分之一左右。是的，也许十分之一。这一定反映了一种困惑、不解，甚至是获得这项权利的男性根本无法理解被赋予的东西意味着什么。想必女性也是如此。这是一种如此新颖的理解政治以及个体在政体中角色的方式，以至于人们根本无法真正把握它。
And maybe it's a bit like about slavery, you know, where similar debates are happening and it's kind of striking that Olymp de Gouges, an abolitionist, as well as an enthusiast for female suffrage, that she is, she's arguing for things that today we take so for granted that we can't even understand how people could possibly have thought otherwise. And yet the fact that she is so scorned and despised and mocked does, I think, remind us of just how revolutionary principles that today we completely accept once were. And I think there's a case for saying that, you know, for all her soft spot for Louis the 16th, for all the fact that she dedicates her Declaration of the Rights of Women to
也许这有点像关于奴隶制的讨论，当时也发生了类似的辩论。令人瞩目的事实是，奥兰普·德古热作为一名废奴主义者，同时也是女性选举权的狂热支持者，她所主张的事情在今天看来是如此理所当然，以至于我们甚至无法理解人们当时怎么可能会有不同的想法。然而，她遭到如此多的嘲弄、鄙视和嘲笑，这确实提醒了我们，今天我们完全接受的革命原则，在当时是多么的激进。而且我认为完全可以说，尽管她对路易十六抱有一丝温情，尽管她将自己的《女权宣言》献给了
Marie Antoinette, there is a case for saying that the de Limptogouge is as radical, if not more radical than any of the revolutionaries that we've talked about in this series. Tom, I could not agree with you more, I think, actually. By far she's the most radical. So all that the men are arguing for, Robespierre, the Maras, whatever, it's within the bounds of the imagination. There have been republics, right?
玛丽·安托瓦内特，但德古热的激进程度完全不亚于，甚至可能超过了我们在本系列节目中谈论过的任何革命者。汤姆，我不能更同意你的看法了，事实上，我认为她绝对是最激进的。所以男人们所争论的一切——罗伯斯庇尔、马拉（Marat）之流——都还在想象力的范围之内。历史上曾经有过共和国，对吧？
I mean, England executed its king. It has been the Dutch Republic. There's the Roman Republic. I mean, England executed its king. There has been the Dutch Republic, there's the Roman Republic. It is perfectly plausible to imagine that, you might think it's a bad thing, which a lot of people in France obviously did, but you can imagine it. It's not making your head hurt to think about it. But I think with this, what's clearly the case when she presents that declaration of the rights of women, you know, when she unveils it, the ridicule, the contempt, the
我的意思是，英国处决过自己的国王。曾经有过荷兰共和国，还有罗马共和国。设想这种可能性是完全合理的，你可能会认为这是一件坏事，法国的许多人显然也这么认为，但你至少可以想象它。思考这件事并不会让人头疼。但对于德古热而言，显而易见的是，当她提出那份《女权宣言》时，当她将其公之于众时，迎面而来的嘲弄、蔑视和
disbelief that greets it is a sign that a lot of people just simply cannot imagine a world in which women exercise political power. Including women. Yeah, including women themselves exactly that. That they are, as it were, I don't want to say prisoners of the same imagination because that casts people in the past as somehow lesser than us. We're more enlightened and there and I don't generally like that kind of language, but I think it is fair to say that just as we are trapped by our own preconceptions in ways that we don't even recognize, they are absolutely
难以置信，恰恰说明了许多人根本无法想象一个由女性行使政治权力的世界。包括女性在内。是的，包括女性自己，正是如此。她们可以说是……我不想用“被同样的想象力所禁锢”这种说法，因为那会将过去的人贬低得不如我们开明。我们更开明，而她们……我通常不喜欢那种语言，但我认为可以公平地说，正如我们被自身的先入之见所困扰而浑然不觉一样，她们也绝对
trapped by this. But I think it also suggests that we are beneficiaries of, you know, the events that we're describing in this series in ways that we may not appreciate, that we may mistake for truths so self-evident that they don't need to be argued for, that that's not what they are at all. That they are in fact kind of radical intellectual ideological innovations that ultimately succeed because we come to feel, yeah, they're absolutely right. But when they are first proposed, just seem absolutely kind of mad. Well, Tom, there are a lot of people in the world right now
被这一点所禁锢了。但这也表明，我们是本系列节目中所描述的那些事件的受益者，其程度可能超出了我们的想象；我们可能会把它们误认为是不证自明的真理，无需加以论证，但事实根本不是这样。它们实际上是一种激进的、思想上的意识形态创新，最终之所以成功，是因为我们后来觉得：“是的，它们完全正确。”但当它们最初被提出时，却显得极其疯狂。好吧，汤姆，在我们录制这集节目的当下，世界上有很多人
when we're recording this who would listen to this episode and would say they are mad. I mean there are people right now, you know, in the people who are currently administering Afghanistan or indeed Iran who would say, you know, a lot of what Olymp de Guzs was arguing was bonkers. So maybe we shouldn't be entirely complacent about it, I guess. Yes.
如果听到这一集，会觉得这些想法简直疯狂。我的意思是，现在有些人，比如目前管理阿富汗或者伊朗的人，就会认为奥兰普·德古热所争论的大部分内容都是荒谬绝伦的。所以我想我们也许不应该对此感到完全沾沾自喜。是的。
Well, it's, um, yes. Um, but it's, it's nice to hear you finally say something good about the revolution. So Theo will be pleased about that. Well, I'm not saying something good about the revolution. I'm saying about Olymp de Guzs because as we will discover in a future episode, Revolution doesn't treat her well, does it? No, does not treat her well, which is yet another black mark, I'm afraid. So, Charlie Good Tom, that was absolutely fascinating.
嗯，这……是的。不过，听到你终于对革命说了一些好话，这挺不错的，西奥（Theo）听了肯定会高兴的。好吧，我不是在说革命的好话，我是在说奥兰普·德古热的好话，因为正如我们将在未来的节目中所发现的，革命对她并不好，不是吗？是的，对她一点也不好，这恐怕又是革命的一个黑点。所以，说得好，汤姆，那真是太迷人了。
And kind of overdue, we should have, you know, we've done a lot about men in the revolution. We've done quite a lot about women as well. Well, we have, we did start with a woman, I guess. So next week, we will be getting back to the narrative, won't we? Because I think we left it last time with the Prussians. Cliffhanger. they were approaching Paris they're 120 miles away and they've just turned to finish off the last French army at Valmy and listeners will be excited to hear that there is going to
而且早就该讲了，我们讲了太多关于革命中男性的故事。关于女性的故事其实我们也讲了不少。嗯，我们确实是以一个女性的故事开头的。所以下周，我们将回归叙事主线，对吧？因为我记得上次我们讲到普鲁士人时留下了悬念。生死悬于一线。他们正在逼近巴黎，距离只有120英里，而且他们刚刚掉头去消灭最后残存的法军——瓦尔米战役（Valmy）。听众们一定会兴奋地听到，
be a thrilling twist to the story we love a thrilling twist on the rest is his way so Tom what could people do if they wanted to hear that episode now literally now? They could sign up to the Rest Is History Club and not only will they be able to hear both the two episodes yet to come, but they will get a slew, Dominic, a slew of additional benefits. And just to be very clear, we are a mixed club and Tom, do we treat our male and female members equally?
这个故事将迎来一个惊心动魄的转折。我们太爱“历史大转折”了，这就是《历史余音》（The Rest Is History）的风格。所以汤姆，如果人们现在——字面意义上的现在——就想听到那一集，他们该怎么做？他们可以注册加入“历史余音俱乐部”（The Rest Is History Club），不仅能听到接下来尚未播出的两集节目，还能获得大量——多米尼克，是大量的额外福利。为了以防万一，我们要明确说明，我们是一个混合俱乐部。汤姆，我们对待男女会员是平等的吗？
Yeah, we were all about equality We treat them equally badly and on that bombshell We will see you next time for the most exciting twist in European history. Goodbye. Bye. Bye Now, Tom, as you know, I am not just a man of history. I'm also known for my involvement in the performing arts. Are you now? I must confess that early on in my acting career, my stage presence did come under a little scrutiny from Britain's finest newspapers. Oh yes, this is the famous notorious one-star review in the Scotsmanism.
是的，我们全员致力于平等。我们对他们同样糟糕。伴随着这个重磅炸弹，我们下期节目再见，去领略欧洲历史上最令人兴奋的转折。再见。再见。再见。那么，汤姆，如你所知，我不只是一位历史学者，我也因涉足表演艺术而闻名。是吗？我必须承认，在我的演艺生涯早期，我的舞台表现确实受到过英国最优秀的几家报纸的一些审视。哦，是的，这就是《苏格兰人报》（The Scotsmanism）那篇著名的、声名狼藉的一星评价。
Yeah, and I will remind the listeners that in Scotland, they order their reviews in a different way, so one is at the top and five stars is the worst review you could get, so we were very happy with that one-star review. But like a lot of great masters of their craft, Tom, I learned from it. I grew, I evolved, I knew I would bide my time before returning to the boards. And guess what? You're not! No! Yes! Tom, I have to tell you, I have returned to the boards, I'm performing once again, and the brilliant news for our listeners is that you can go and you can be transfixed by my performance right now because I am honoured and privileged to appear in the latest Sherlock and co adventure,
是的，我要提醒听众朋友们，在苏格兰，他们的评分方式与众不同，1分是最高的，5星是最差的评价，所以我们对那个一星评价非常满意。但就像许多伟大的手艺大师一样，汤姆，我从中吸取了教训。我成长了，我蜕变了，我知道我会在重返舞台之前韬光养晦。你猜怎么着？你不会的！不！是的！汤姆，我必须告诉你，我重返舞台了，我又开始表演了，而对我们的听众来说绝佳的消息是，你现在就可以去欣赏我的表演并为之着迷，因为我很荣幸、也很特权地参演了最新的《歇洛克与公司》（Sherlock & Co）大冒险——
the adventure of the Norwood Builder. Please tell me that you are playing the Norwood Builder. I'm playing a much better character. I'm playing Hector McFarlane, a solicitor from Blackheath accused of murder. Goodness, as Lestrade's officers bear down on me, Tom, I have nowhere else to turn but to 221B Baker Street. This is amazing, Dominic. And the fact that you were cast in this role, it has nothing to do with the fact that Sherlock
《诺伍德的建筑师》（The Adventure of the Norwood Builder）。请告诉我你演的就是那个诺伍德的建筑师。我演了一个好得多的角色。我饰演黑希思（Blackheath）的律师、被指控谋杀的黑克托尔·麦克法兰（Hector McFarlane）。天哪，随着莱斯特雷德（Lestrade）的警官们向我逼近，汤姆，我除了前往贝克街221B号之外别无去处。这太棒了，多米尼克。你被选中出演这个角色，该不会是因为《歇洛克
& Co is a goal-hanger production like this one. Well, very much like this one with a better acting, I think it's fair to say. It's a stablemate of ours. They are a massive show. They get 10 million downloads. Outside, I believe, the Archers, this is the biggest audio drama in Britain. Well, I have no doubt dominate that it is more interesting than The Archers. It genuinely is brilliant. So my son is a massive Sherlock and co-officionado.
&公司》和我们一样是个挂名捞钱的制作吧？嗯，跟我们这个非常像，只不过演技更好，我觉得这样说挺公平的。它是我们的同门师兄弟。它们是一个大制作节目。它们的下载量达到了1000万次。除了《射手座》（The Archers）之外，我相信这是英国最大的音频广播剧。好吧，多米尼克，毫无疑问，它比《射手座》更有趣。它确实非常精彩。所以我的儿子就是《歇洛克与公司》的超级粉丝。
It basically goes through all the original short stories and the short stories that are often forgotten in modern day adaptations. It transposes Sir Arthur Conan Doyle's narratives to the modern day. So Watson himself is making the podcast while they're doing the adventures. You can pick up any adventure you want. You don't have to follow the whole series to get stuck in. It is absolutely brilliant. Do you know who else thinks it's brilliant, Tom? The Guardian newspaper. One of those prized one-star reviews? No, a five-star. They said, and I quote, very funny, mildly sweary and hugely popular. Do you want to know what the Times said?
它基本上涵盖了所有原著短篇小说，以及那些在现代改编中常被遗忘的短篇。它将阿瑟·柯南·道尔爵士的故事背景转换到了现代。因此，华生在他们经历冒险的同时自己制作播客。你可以挑选你想听的任何一个冒险故事。你不必非得按顺序听完整部剧才能入坑。这真的太精彩了。汤姆，你知道还有谁觉得它精彩吗？《卫报》。难道是那种备受瞩目的差评？不，是五星好评。他们是这样评价的——原话是：幽默风趣、略带脏话且人气极高。你想知道《泰晤士报》是怎么说的吗？
It said, a breakneck series that Gen Zed, or Gen Z as members of it say, that Gen Zed is hooked on. Wow, and now that you're appearing on the show, I mean that will confirm the hook, won't it? It absolutely will, and the Guardian listeners will be beside themselves with joy. So everybody, please listen to Sherlock & Co. The Adventure of the Norwood Builder. It's multi-part, it's brilliant, part one is out now. Jump right in wherever you get your podcasts. And here is a clip from that very episode. He was murdered. Supposedly. No body has been found yet, Watson.
它说，这是一部让Z世代——正如Z世代年轻人自己所说的那样——为之着迷的极速剧集。哇塞，现在你也要出演这档节目了，这意味着他们会彻底沦陷，对吧？绝对会的，卫报的听众们肯定会高兴得合不拢嘴。所以各位，请收听《歇洛克与合伙人》（Sherlock & Co.）之《诺伍德的建筑师》（The Adventure of the Norwood Builder）。这是个多集系列，非常精彩，第一部分现已上线。在各大播客平台随时开听。以下是该集节目的精彩片段。他被谋杀了。据说是这样的。华生，目前还没找到尸体。
Yet, but… Now listen, you said you would hear me out, didn't you? Do you want to just dial it down a bit, Hector? Would you? Would you dial it down when you're smeared over every paper? Look at this! Look at this! In the Times, here, look. Solicitor suspected for contractor disappearance. The Telegraph. Solicitor faces long arm of law. The Daily Mail. Bully of Black Heath.
虽然还没找到，但是……听着，你答应过会听我解释的，对吧？赫克托，你能不能稍微冷静点？行吗？当你被各大报纸污蔑成这样时，你还能冷静得下来吗？你看看这个！看看这个！《泰晤士报》这儿，你瞧。律师涉嫌承包商失踪案。《每日电讯报》。律师面临法律制裁。《每日邮报》。布莱克希特的恶霸。
Elite London lawyer facing murder charge. This is just... this is... this is... The Guardian. Here, look at this. Old Acre Murder. How neoliberal materialism and cursed the all-stop home renovations are the real killers of the working... Oh, well that one goes on a bit. Yeah, we get the point. Do you? Do you? I'm not sure you do.
伦敦精英律师面临谋杀指控。这简直……这简直……这简直是……《卫报》。来，看看这个。奥尔克雷谋杀案。新自由主义物质至上主义以及该死的无休止房屋翻修，才是残害工人的真正凶手……哦，好吧，那篇写得有点长。行了，我们懂这意思了。是吗？你们真的懂吗？我看不见得。
The Daily Sports. Big Job Love. McFarlane's wife's steamy romp with missing builder. I mean, look, there's a thought bubble above my wife's head saying, knob the builder, can he fix it? Hector. The speech bubble, I don't know as well.
《每日体育报》。大干一场的爱。麦克法兰的妻子与失踪建筑商偷情。我的意思是，你看，我妻子头顶上居然有个对话气球写着：睡了建筑商，他能修好吗？赫克托。那其实是个对话框，我也说不准。
Here's your extension, love. I mean this is just... The son. Cannibal Hector. McFarlane confesses to eating Norwood Tradesman. You confess to what? Sorry. I didn't confess to a damn thing! I said I was hungry for justice!
这是你的扩建工程，亲爱的。我的意思是这简直……《太阳报》。食人魔赫克托。麦克法兰招认吃掉诺伍德工匠。你招认了什么？抱歉。我根本没招认任何该死的事情！我说的是我对正义充满渴望！
That's all! It is slander! It's disgraceful! It's bloody humiliating! Could we perhaps return to the chain of events as you, not the press, perceive them? There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
就这些！这纯属诽谤！太无耻了！简直是奇耻大辱！我们能否回到由你——而不是媒体——所还原的事件经过上来？本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。